and I'm gonna start this one Chris
because this has been bugging me and let
me let me just say that here's my pre
grievance yeah the the tribalism that
has infected our politics and our lie
everything that we do is tied to how it
affects our view of the world and and I
say this as it relates to football
because the same Raiders fans who were a
month ago clamoring for the Chiefs to
cut tyree kill after Tyree keel found
himself back on the wrong side
potentially of the law and the NFL's
personal conduct policy are twisting
themselves into knots
to try to justify the Raiders decision
to sign Richie incognito well oh oh it's
a it's it's a low-risk move oh if he has
one false move they'll just cut him I
mean come on folks he shouldn't be
getting this chance the guy has such an
extensive history of off-field
misbehaviour i don't know which chance
this is for him yeah second it's not the
third right I think it's his fifth or
sixth second chance by the time we boil
it all down yeah and it's so predictable
and I've been dealing with for the last
24 hours
Raiders fans are up in arms because God
forbid we point out that maybe it wasn't
a good idea for the Oakland Raiders to
sign Richie incognito that maybe they
shouldn't give this guy another
opportunity to play in the NFL that
maybe they shouldn't take away someone
else's opportunity who hasn't done
anything erratic unpredictable or bad
off the field and give that person the
privilege of playing in the NFL not
reach incognito but that and that that's
you know it's that just bugs me because
it is so so easily predictable it is
tied to rooting interest and people will
twist themselves and contort their
brains to say whatever they have to say
to support their team and if it's any
other team I mean if Richie incognito
was signed by the Chargers the Broncos
of the Chiefs Raiders fans would be up
in arms right now but because he was
signed by the Raiders Chris they are
fully and completely supportive of the
move because it's our team and how dare
you say anything that in any way
scrutinizes or criticizes our team yeah
I mean it certainly got a fishy look to
it III mean I got to say that and I know
Richie incognito you know when he's
playing good he's
really damn good and i know mike Mayock
and Jon Gruden you know I believe them
they wanted to sign the guy you know to
add a little toughness culture maybe
their old line and that I get that
aspect of it but you know also at the
same time yeah it's not a great look for
your organization you know I would
challenge anybody out there I mean is
there is there any player with a laundry
list of issues that it can compete with
Richie incognito I mean it's a pretty
extensive list here we're talking about
of off the visits pretty amazing
actually and you're right it's not the
second chance it's not the third chance
it's more like the fifth or six or
seventh chance and guys aren't gonna
guys on the you know in the locker room
who might not be happy with you know
some of his views on lives and the
things he says or does you know they're
not gonna mess with a guy like Richie
Don King incognito first of all he's
tough he's big but he's got the crazy
white guy card and everybody's scared of
the crazy white guy in the locker room
because the crazy white guy is the guy
who says you know the crazy white guy is
the guy who you know makes makes a mess
of a funeral home or says I'm gonna go
out into my car and get the shotgun okay
I've been around a few of those guys in
the locker room i day and age and that's
what Richie incognito does too so you're
never gonna hear people in the locker
room speak up against it because they're
afraid of him the way I might look in
the organization all of it but
regardless yes it does seem like he has
been given chances that I would argue
that other people in football have not
been given those chances and you
everybody out there can connect the dots
until why they think there's a lot of
theories out there let me give you an
example of how Raiders fans are bending
over backwards to support this signing
and and I'm never one to tell anyone how
to grieve when you lose a close family
member or someone you care about deeply
it tears you apart right the world stops
spinning like you you see the rest of
the world going about its business and
you say how in the world is the rest of
the world moving when my world has
collapsed around me right and and and
I've been there I've lost both of my
parents and and people do handle grief
in different ways that sometimes they
don't want anything to do them not going
to the funeral home I mean there's all
sorts of things people do
but I still think we have to expect
people to keep their behavior within the
bounds of what's socially acceptable and
the idea of tearing up a funeral home
and threatening to shoot it up and you
have the the artillery in your in your
car to back it up yeah that's a problem
and and what came out last night Chris
two days before the incident at the
funeral home he was at the house of his
90 year old grandmother and he blamed
her for the death of his father and he
punched the hole in the wall and he
ripped a security system panel off the
wall and he pleaded guilty to two more
counts that no one knew about and I hope
the Raiders knew about this before they
signed it if they didn't know about it
well you know what if they didn't know
about that before they signed him they
need to cut him because it's some when
he visited the team earlier this year
that mike Mayock has to ask that
question rich you what else is out there
that we possibly don't know about
there's so many things that have gone on
for the last 15 years in your life on
and off the field is there anything else
out there we don't know about no that's
it that's everything if that happened
and he didn't tell them about that
incident and he had pleaded guilty
already to two additional misdemeanor
counts he's got three guilty plea counts
on misdemeanor charges that that will
set him up for an NFL suspension that's
the other side of this he's not playing
week one there's no way the NFL is gonna
let this guy on the field to start the
season after these guilty pleas in April
I just I don't know how the Raiders
justify this and and I know how they do
it because they think hey it's a lowerin
we're paying in peanuts and if he acts
up we'll get rid of him but I should
that person given his history Chris
should that person even have the
opportunity to act up should he ever be
wearing the shield again they tell us
time and again NFL playing by having and
having a job in the NFL is a privilege
not a right and and the idea that it's a
low-risk proposition doesn't make it
right to put this guy back on a team now
Mike I mean I agree with a lot of what
you're saying you know I mean it's a
yeah it's it's it's risky okay it
doesn't look right at a base level oh
and and yes I mean again you know this
is a guy that's we've seen people get in
trouble in the NFL for
I think less egregious things and you
know at the very least yeah this is a
questionable signing by the Oakland
Raiders and we talk about it a lot when
you're a good player you get away with a
few more things than you should but I
think this one you know even passes that
that test a little further than normal
in my eyes so I'm crazy I think to
overcome this history you've got to be
random McDaniel Larry Allen you've got
to be one of the I mean a guy who's
about to turn 30
yeah he's a multi-time Pro Bowler but
he's not a hall-of-famer he's not a
consistent all-pro I just I think that
sliding scale of how good you have to be
to justify that umpteenth second chance
it just doesn't fit that makes it even
more confusing that this isn't a great
great player that you're bringing onto
your team and you're doing so despite a
history of incidents it goes all the way
back to 2004 and look one of the
incidents and and I'm amazed that this
doesn't get the attention should write
2012 yeah golf outing with the Miami
Dolphin tear on the golf course with his
club right I mean and there were any
piece sprayed water in her face he was
bothering her all day long he ended up
being fined $55,000 by the Dolphins he
ended up paying roughly $30,000 in a
settlement to this individual and nobody
ever did anything about that should have
been that should have been the moment
where the Dolphins cut him I never
happened no I mean I here and here we
are we're talking about Ezekiel Elliott
who I'm not saying you know was good and
what he did but we're talking about you
know oh the leagues you know look into
it cuz he bumped a guy I mean and I get
I'm not condoning his behavior but
certainly seems a little less egregious
than Richie incognito who's you know on
his knife 9th public offense of the
decade at least at this point so yeah I
don't get it Mike I don't like the look
of it and I don't understand why this
guy has gotten six or seven chances and
I could show you other people in
football who are good football players
who haven't been granted this many
chances to come back and continue to
play and get another chance to prove
themselves
I'm not condoning in any way shape or
form what Kareem hunt the Browns running
back did last year in Cleveland but he
got eight games and we've seen the video
he got eight games for that and I'm not
saying he should have gotten less but
I'm saying if that's the standard for
what he did one time only first offense
if that's the standard this is the
opportunity for the NFL to rewind
because the NFL's never suspended the
guy before back in 2013 with Jonathan
Martin the team suspended him for
conduct detrimental to the club the NFL
has never taken action against this guy
this is the opportunity three counts
that he pled guilty to that he has yet
to be disciplined for and I think the
NFL needs to look into all these other
incidents this is their chance to take a
stand regarding the conduct that we've
seen from Richie incognito over the
years and I think if Kareem Hunt gets
eight games for a first offense for what
we saw in that video how do you not give
Richie incognito at least eight games
for the three pending counts and
everything else that he's done in the
past ya know I think that's it's it's
common sense to me you're right and you
know hopefully you say in this and
that's talking about this will maybe get
the NFL on their horse a little bit to
get you up through this situation and
figure it out either way but you know
the Raiders need to know to at some
point I mean if they're gonna go into
the season with this guy and thinking he
might be their starting guard
you got to make something happen I
didn't get a chance to rant about my
playoff I wanted to rant about maybe
expanding the playoffs I didn't get
there cuz you hog all the time but
that's sorry I'm sorry don't worry we'll
have more time more time yes there is
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports